and do everything motivate do the same
movements okay definitely push me mags
[Music]
here with my buddy max Yves Ukraine
again some of you might know max from
our last video a lot more fun deep under
key under a nuclear bunker but today max
is bringing us into an abandoned bus
station which doesn't sound that
interesting but he assured me it is and
we got to get over this right oh alright
we are getting closer to the place we
need so Peter I would like to ask you
once in yeah you talk only when I say
okay is there law breaking here max
actually not in our country's assistant
no it's not a law breaking it's like
trespassing but no one can say a word to
you really they can just ask you to
leave their territory and that's it this
is a maximum what they can do but for us
it's not a problem we are getting in and
we are doing our business indirect
business which is showing the wildness
of this place the smokestack barbed wire
I want to make sure inside my own
entrance is still okay it's still ready
for use and it even seems like my glove
system you keep a set of gloves here at
all times
let's normalize our bris
and then here we have Olympians from
alternative buses and our target is to
better the long journey long way through
all of them in order to get into the
circus does it mean object we need not
much talking and do everything move it
to see movements okay
[Applause]
Yeah right what's the deal with all
these yeah don't get lost on the buses
first
okay max so what was this it's just a
place to service these things to
maintain the boss's old safety so all
Soviet times right yeah original safety
posters
why don't they scrap the metal like take
the metal and sell it so this is where
they did like changes
once they even had the command center
over there look at they built him a huge
glass huge window so it's a responsible
person director of this mass function
she could watch
oh this area right which passes are
coming which are leaving and so what the
troops make sound different I usually
getting scared to exist noise I think
somebody is walking too deep to find out
is it a god why is it like what Brooks
so lucky when we went under the tunnels
that was a whole different ecosystem of
sounds yeah when we went under the city
and this has my god I'm saying what was
intact with you here like metal bang
it's like the heat maybe you can be you
know contracting
Oh
where we going next so I don't know when
you're watching this but it is this is
July July 11th and the year to 2020 so
we're in the middle of coronavirus
nothing's a lock stop a law here on the
streets as far as people wearing masks
and whatnot but it's actually the
greatest risk so I've just been trying
to think of video ideas that are away
from people for the most part I met max
thank God no no go up there max that's
how you should be infected - that's what
no this is definitely not how you should
have it's a very bad idea so my wife was
like I said I'm going to the max damn I
said I'm going with Max again and
Vaness some abandoned bus station and
I'm thinking you know like telling her
tell your mom when she watches it you
know it's not dangerous I don't want her
mom to be worried because you know four
daughters husbands out crawling around
buses and she was like well you're not
least so my Soviet mother is not worried
at all little bricks on the age they're
like urbex awards age categories that's
cool what is this okay what is the
resistance of engines a dress to wear a
Boojum esta an excellent working place
solid chest oh cool
and magazine with different rules
schedule bosses
so it is looking the same as in cricket
the condition is 100% same as in fretted
right it's like everyone just wonder if
there is a lack of financial this is the
only one problem in Ukraine all the
farmers of it
factories Institute's
laboratories whatever everything is
getting abandoned because of no luck
lack of fire financing but I mean they
decide to close it one day and then they
just leave guys walk out the door yeah
they command center oh yeah there it is
so the administrator was sitting here in
the green chair looking at looking out
all the - all the workers making sure
that workers being done right I always
wanted to find this mole bunker
somewhere wrong but no no nuclear
bunkers in here
I was there in the bus max we got a
different way yeah yeah smell the oil
[Music]
in a fit ecological disaster that's for
sure guard
they could do something so too long here
looks like a UFO it's like a UFO guys in
the former Soviet Union you see a lot of
very interesting architecture even for
places that were very utilitarian like
this the bus depot repair place I mean
this could be this could be all sorts of
things it could be a concert hall it can
be a massive market it's got the
skylights above all natural light and
just very very cool dimensions dude come
on
see this is one well one of many aspects
in the West growing up we didn't know
about the very interesting architecture
and a lot of its you know brutalist and
heavy and harsh but obviously this needs
a remodel but when's the last time you
saw a roofline like that
so beautiful max is this one your
favorite places
you keep that's a no-go huh
we're not going through this like a
couple of years ago with my own hands
I made an exit to the rooftop so here
this is it yeah yeah
okay guys we've reached the top and on
the top it is this is wow it looks like
a black sand desert but it's the rooftop
guys with small trees
it's amazing the trees are growing out
of this
what was this before this this top space
what's this building over here in old
factory into Wow there's a very strong
breeze coming up here
it's a massive space this is another
first I've had a lot of firsts in this
city you know that and this country I've
had a lot of firsts Steph you could
never concern your head like come up
with you have to you have to come into
that's why I like it her to be honest a
lot of discovery no you said you want to
go somewhere else I wanted to check out
another possibility okay I heard that at
the moment one of the bridges in Kiev is
available for a visit
do you think we'll make it max is taking
us up here very time
that's like your legs of a spider
from the top is amazing
Thank You our next outfit exists inside
rage
nice job yeah
getting closer
[Music]
not really
oh yeah that's beautiful
and that is some sketchy [ __ ] what does
it mean sketches get you like scary
skittish not stable freaky freaky swear
words but I think it's a good pure head
actually that make it calm oh sit sit
I'm from USA where are you from
Jesus Christ all right America political
yes oh nice to meet you okay thanks for
asking
oh my god thank you for climbing I
didn't actually definitely push me mags
okay that's the end of this video if you
want to be pushed and keep this is your
man chance max I'll leave his Instagram
at the bottom I'll scare the hell out of
you bring you an interesting stuff make
you feel alive
till next video you can be a roofers
your roofer exploring old city and to
another city in Ukraine and we're
talking about this feeling of vertigo
and never thought I was scared of
heights